can you share a specific example of how
your first few short films help get a
feature film off the ground for you well
the first few short projects that i did
i was very fortunate to have a couple of
great publications around the world
right about them i was able to get in
some wonderful places and have people
watched them and because those two
things happened there was some respect
for the work that I was doing and it
attracted some attention from various
producers and I started getting some
phone calls about projects and when that
started happening I knew that I had some
options on the table which allowed me to
be a little selective about the things
that I choose because like I was saying
earlier I see my career as a as a ladder
or a staircase that you're kind of
building up with each project and you're
kind of figuring out what direction you
want to take and the choices you make
directly impact which staircase you
ascend I think without directing the
shorts that I did those got some
international attention from various
publications I remember one day I woke
up and followed was featured in Spain's
biggest horror magazine there it's a
horrible ugh for photographs which is
their main film publication and I
thought that was wild because I didn't
send it to them they just found it and
when things like that happen you start
realizing that people are watching your
work and paying attention to what you're
doing and without those experiences I
wouldn't have had the opportunity to
direct desires of the heart because I
wouldn't have had the experience or the
attention
you